well more on that China has given its
take on what's gone on with the Wagner
Mutiny it says it will not affect
relations with Russia and that the
Strategic partnership between the two
countries will continue
the Wagner group incident is Russia's
Internal Affairs as a friendly neighbor
and comprehensive strategic partner of
coordinating in the new era China
supports and believes that Russia can
Safeguard its National stability to
achieve development and prosperity China
and Russia have maintained close on
sound relationships at all levels
we can speak now to Victor Gower who is
vice president at the center for China
in globalization he joins us now from
Beijing thank you for joining the
program sir so that's the official line
from China what do you think how do you
think the Chinese leadership is really
viewing this attempted Mutiny in Russia
over the weekend
thank you very much for having me I
think the uh Wagner incident if we use
that term has really taken many
countries and many people by complete
surprise including I would say China
China was not prepared to see an
incident like this and China did not
know exactly what's the implication and
what's the reason behind it at the very
beginning of the incident However I
truly believe that the Wagner incident
however you define it will not affect
China Russian relations and friendship
and cooperation why first of all right
now a group does not represent the
totality of Russia it does not represent
the totality of the Russian
armed forces and it does not represent
everything on the Russian side as far as
the Ukrainian war is concerned and
within 24 hours it seems that there is a
satisfactory resolution of the Wagner
group as well as its leader and
hopefully let me interrupt you there let
me interrupt you there doesn't the
Wagner interaction contradict The
Narrative of Putin as a strong leader
who enjoys full support of his people if
Putin's rule is unstable isn't
supporting him bad for business
I personally don't see that in that
light why because uh recording and uh
president of pyro Russia the defense
minister uhu as well as the chief of
staff uh general
simoff of Russia Etc they all are loyal
to uh President Putin including the head
of the Wagner group even though he had
uh he believes a lot of grievances
against the defense Ministry defense
minister the leader of the Russian army
Etc it's not the same as if for example
he himself is now Rebellion against the
President Putin okay okay
so you don't think it's dangerous for a
country to support and keep such a large
non-state military group
I mean isn't there a possibility if
they've done it once they'll do it again
first of all other things being equal to
have a mercenary group like Wagner in
any country is abnormal it's not the
normal thing it's not a very normal
phenomenon to start with however even
the history in recent decades in Russia
and given the fact that in the Ukrainian
War this Wagner group has played its own
role for good or for bad that's another
value judgment therefore I think we need
to see the Wagner group in the context
of the recent history of Russia and how
to deal with this Wagner group is
completely an internal matter of Russia
therefore China has no role to play
China does not have any advice for the
Russians as to how to deal with this and
I personally hope eventually there will
be a resolution of the Wagner group it
doesn't seem that the Wagner group will
really be the end of the day anytime
soon they may still continue to operate
either in Barrow Russia or in Ukraine
itself or in some of the African
countries therefore they may take around
for quite some time to come for good or
for bad
Victor gal good to get your thoughts
vice president at the center for China
and globalization speaking to us there
from Beijing thank you
thank you very much for having me